[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring in Lewis rck you can't blame
him for anything other than being great
ESPN NFL and college football analyst
what's m Parson's doing
here yeah you know Dan there there's
been a little bit of a movement amongst
today's players to kind of clap back at
the media especially when the you know
when the coverage turns a little bit
negative or critical and look as a
former player I sometimes understand
what they're saying when they feel as
though you know the criticism crosses a
line to where it becomes personal and
becomes a little bit over the top it
becomes a little bit more dramatic and
not really objective and I get that
because sometimes it does get that way
uh when it comes to Dallas of course
you're you're exactly right we all talk
about Dallas too much because everyone
likes to hear about Dallas and Micah
knows on the plus side he's got
people from around the globe talking
about him as the next Lawrence Taylor if
he was playing for Jacksonville would
they be talking about him the same way
as they're talking about him now and
that's not any slight against
Jacksonville
no um and when things don't go great for
him and his quarterback of course they
get a lot of attention but you know what
I do Dan I will say I do get a little
bit though about how
we have to be
careful to not swing from one week to
the next going this guy absolutely
stinks didn't put in any work didn't you
know is is a guy who's letting his team
down to the next week going this guy is
transcended we've never seen anything
like it we we got to stop doing that
because we know better meaning we
meaning all of us as analysts and that
we all know that the truth probably lies
somewhere in the middle and that there's
always reasons for swings right in terms
of player performance and usually that's
that that reason is here I'm G to really
break something you know that nobody's
ever heard before on on your show yeah
but everybody has hot takes though Lewis
that's why that's why it's reactionary
it's week to week it's oh the Cowboys
are terrible they can't win with Dak
Prescott to Dak playing great the other
night to hey if he plays like that
defense plays like like it it just goes
along with the territory unfortunately
but I I just think context then is
sometimes something that we need to
provide a little bit sometimes like
right so if Dak is throwing a bunch of
interceptions right if he has two three
interceptions in a game or mic is not
you know getting a lot of pressures or
hits or hurries then tell me why tell me
why why why isn't it was Micah getting
double team were they sliding
protections to him all the time was he
playing with a bad ankle you know this
takes me back to like my scouting days
man I remember this so vividly one time
we were in a we were in a free agent
meeting once and we were evaluating a
linebacker and our posi position coach
in Washington at the time had crushed
this dude crushed him and we were all
sitting there going wait a minute like
we all like to a man have said like this
guy's like one of the top players at his
position and he was like nope I I don't
see it we're gonna have to talk about
that I don't see it I think this guy
sucks blah and I remember I asked him I
said what games did you
watch he and then he points to like four
or five games I'm going do you know that
he is coming off of a high ankle sprain
was playing through it was advised not
to play and he was like ah because you
mean so that's why he didn't have the
explosiv and couldn't run that's the
kind of thing I think sometimes if a guy
has a bad day he has a bad day and
everybody's subject to criticism I'm
just saying I think let's just take it
the next step and go well why do you
think this guy is stinking this week
what do you think happened are the
receivers contributing to dax's
interceptions could it be protection
could he be getting hit all those those
are the kind of things that I think we
need to do just to make sure that we're
not just swinging from one end to the
other that's all I don't think we have a
great team in football this year feels
like you have probably a three- tiered
system where you may have you know five
or six teams that could be up there then
you have a lot in the middle and then
you have the Panthers and some of those
teams you know and the bears at the
bottom there um is that good for
football that you don't have a great
team yeah I I actually I think it is
because or do you think there is a great
team yeah no I I think there's some
really really good teams but you know
just kind of go along with what we were
just talking about right now at this
point in the year um none of them have
really separated themselves as we could
see right San Francisco just two weeks
ago we were saying that this team could
just absolutely smack around any team in
the NFL anytime that they wanted they
could just roll their helmet out there
and they were going to win well
Cleveland saying hey have you noticed
the kind of points we've allowed through
the first quarter of this season have
you noticed we're on a historical Pace
yeah no you'd haven't noticed about it
you know why because everybody doesn't
talk about you know our coaching staff
the same way they talk about Kyle
Shanahan and how the fact that every
time he calls a play it's like the
greatest thing that's ever happened
that's why that's why you know you
haven't noticed us so yeah I think it's
good this is what the league wants right
they want games to come down to one-
score games where anybody can win the
game they want parody right that's what
that's how the league is set up and I
think this year we're getting it and
we're getting it with some high level
performances by a couple diff by a
couple different teams that you know
they are going to be there in the end
The Usual Suspects are going to be in
there in the end but here's the cool
thing about this year we have some new
blood kind of coming into it and we saw
it coming last year especially with a
team like Detroit we saw this coming and
that is even
better we're talking to Lewis rid of the
mothership he has a game uh coming up on
Saturday Mississippi State at Arkansas
at noon you did the Colorado game or
should I say the Stanford game against
Colorado at what point did you realize
Dion and Colorado were in in trouble
against Stamford you know I'll tell you
what in the first half in the first half
they hit the kid who who uh who W up
becoming a star that night this wide
receiver named Alec I Manor he beat
Travis Hunter early in the football game
on a go route and he literally dropped
it the ball went right between his hands
and I'm going if they can catch some of
those they could make this a game
because they have fantastic perimeter
players what's hurting Stanford right
now is that they don't have very good
big men and they lost a lot of people
through the transfer portal last year
and they'll they'll fix that but I said
if they could just do that I remember
talking about this at halftime with Mark
Jones and Quint kesik I was like they
could make this interesting the second
half as soon as they came out and hit
that long I believe it like a 90 yard
pass play I think it was I am Manor then
they come back and hit another one about
60 yards I'm going I'm looking at Dion's
face in the Monitor and I can see him
across the field and I could just see
people getting tight and I was like this
team is in trouble right now yeah
they're in trouble and you saw you just
saw the momentum going like this from
one sideline to the other and I and
that's when I sat on TV I was like I
hope you didn't go to bed because you're
missing a heck of a finish here man and
it's um yeah Dion's um to say the least
he's not happy right now he's not happy
yeah because he's never gone through
something like this as a player and now
as a coach you only have so much control
yeah and you know what and and I'm not
saying he's not happy you know with what
he doing or anything like I'm saying
he's not happy with the kind of
competitive character his team is
showing and you saw that in the in the
comments he had to his team in the
locker room after the game where he said
some of you got some of you guys are in
like with the game but a lot of you guys
aren't in love with the game and he's
gonna root that out I'm just telling you
he's gonna root it out he's gonna get
guys in there who who want to play the
way he wants them to play is Dion
running a
business yeah yeah Dion's one of the
brilliant businessmen when it comes to
sports business that we've ever seen
there's no question but I don't but see
what you know what I think what happens
Dan though is people think that's all he
is that he's just everything's just
about the dollar and just about the
notoriety and the commercials the guy is
an old school at heart absolutely oneof
one alpha competitor I know I've seen it
in person as a player when I was with
him in Atlanta and talking to him now
twice and maybe talking to him again
here in the near future for another game
he wants to win
bad and he's building it on Old School
principles but using new school
methodology which is I'm going to
exploit this transfer portable portal to
the utmost because I can it's the rule
and it
works if Bill bellich asked you to be
his
GM that'd be pretty cool
how challenging would it be though bill
has to relinquish that you're in control
of Bill
bellich yeah how would that how would
that work you know what thatd probably
bring back some nightmares for me quite
honestly man um but I I would accept the
challenge that's for sure look he
he's having been coached by him and Nick
at the same time look it's been a long
time since I was under that kind of
pressure from guys who have the kind of
standard that those two have I'm a
different person now it would be it
would be fun I'd love to do it quite
honestly if that opportunity ever came
up of course you'd love to do that kind
of thing it'd be I think the question
though would be for him though like hey
look man we got to work on this kind of
thing together and it's not you know as
long as he would have the right mindset
about it and he could just focus on
football if it ever came to something
like that then of course he he I mean
he's the greatest coach of all time I
don't care what's happened recently with
his football team as far as the some of
the maybe decisions he's made
constructing his staff and the team as
far as tactics scheme strategy there's
nobody that's been on his level nobody
so I think anybody would be better
served to go be around him and help him
out than the than to take the position
that no that wouldn't be a good
opportunity that'd be a great
opportunity' be an opportunity of a
lifetime I just saw where the Eagles
have added Julio Jones and he's had an
interesting career um it it felt like
all he did is produce had one of the
great catches in Super Bowl history
that's forgotten um but he had a
six-year run that was
more I I I I is he a Hall of Famer
because I'm looking at his numbers
compared to like Megatron and Julio
Jones was a better player for a longer
time uh had more big years or maybe
they're both you know Hall of Famers we
know Megatron zardi and Julio Jones Hall
of
Famer yeah you know what it's funny like
I haven't looked at Julio's numbers in a
long time I do know this though for a
long sustained period of time he was the
ultimate Ultimate Weapon the ultimate
producer even when people knew that they
were going to him just like everybody
else who was in the Hall that's what
their role was at that point in time I
think it's because you
know sometimes you you wish guys like
Julio would just have their moments have
their T you know decades long run and
then just get out and not try and hang
on and sign these kind of deals to where
you know they're kind of just going to
be bit spot players and maybe they're
not even going to be able to be
available because they just can't they
don't have the durability anymore but
yeah Julio Jones isn't just only a
potential Hall of Fame player the dude
is just top level when you talk to him
and I know Nick Sabin in particular
absolutely reveres the dude is one of
the greats of all time down in Alabama
man yeah I'm looking at the numbers and
it's because they weren't playing in big
games played in one big game and that
was the Super Bowl but um he wasn't
flashy he didn't have a nickname like
Megatron he wasn't like Antonio Brown
and and I think we just sort of you know
you look at these guys like uh Anquan
bolt you know that that these guys
played uh and you weren't like you had
to find them or you'd go man uh Andre
Johnson like uh you got another 1500
yard season Julio Jones was just one of
those guys it felt like and uh yeah was
just curious if I don't know what he has
left but he's a Julio had had the career
he had with a different team right but
the same kind of team
success Julio Jones on the Dallas
Cowboys it's a no-brainer Julio Jones on
the Green Bay Packers it's a no- break
all right if I gave you Antonio Brown or
Julio Jones for their football just
football yeah oh wow you're guaranteed
Antonio Brown will show up and play and
there won't be any drums
like he used to be right and we're
saying okay so we're saying like Julio's
going to stay Health he's not going to
have HST issues all that other yeah all
right um um Dang d that that's that's a
that's I'm taking hulio because I'm
taking the bigger stronger faster player
the guy who's just more okay so he would
concern you as a former defensive back
in the NFL you'd have more issues with
Julio or Antonio BR
yeah yeah just because
you know big speed wins man man I would
take Antonio Brown yeah I I I just say
big speed big explosiveness wins more
times than we're saying that these guys
could all like if they could play the
same number of snaps yeah over the same
number of year yeah I think Antonio when
he was at his
Peak there were so many yeah he he was
he was so tough and so durable and so
multi-dimensional in terms of all the
different things he could do always been
a big Antonio Brown fan but I love big
speed I love big strong F I will always
take the bigger guy and be more afraid
of the bigger guy than the little guy
and Julio's just standing next to both
of them and I've had a chance to talk to
him both postgame in their
uniform Julio's just a freak man he he
really is he really is Lewis rck former
uh Eagles Washington director of pro
Personnel hopefully you get another
chance hopefully you get another chance
in the front office there uh Mississippi
State at Arkansas that'll be on noon
Eastern with Mark Jones great to talk to
you again safe travels thanks for
joining us of course man thanks a lot
that's Lewis rck of the mother show